elena volochine vous êtes notre chef du
bureau de france 24 à moscou merci
d'être avec nous moscou menacé
journaliste indépendant l'information
soumise à la censure d'état la vérité
fait peur à poutine et le kremlin a
bloqué plusieurs médias oui
effectivement il ya quelques jours les
premiers médias indépendants en ont fait
les frais les chaînes est très
symbolique chaîne web télévision de
jeter la radio echo de moscou et puis il
y eut tout cet arsenal législatif qui a
été mise en place d'abord il a été
interdite par l'état russe d'employer le
mot guerre pour qualifier la guerre et
ensuite cette loi donc sur les faits que
news qui a été voté par le parlement
russe qui est puni jusqu'à 15 ans de
prison ce que l'état russe considérerait
comme de fausses informations sur son
opération spéciale en ukraine comme il
l'appelle alors évidemment si on appelle
les choses par leur nom et de façon
préméditée ce qui prête à interprétation
n'est ce pas dès lors qu'on est accusé
de cela et bien on est passible de cette
peine de 15 ans de prison il faut
rappeler aussi parce qu'on parle
beaucoup du fait de ne pas qualifier
l'opération militaire de guerre etc mais
même le fait d'appeler à des sanctions
contre la russie par exemple dans des
publications ça aussi c'est passible de
prison maintenant c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas le droit de dire que la russie
devrait faire l'objet de sanctions alors
c'est pas ce qu'on fait en général dans
les publications mais on voit au fil des
ans et de ce genre de lois qui se met en
place de lois qui répriment la liberté
d'expression que même une publication
qui relaie les propos de quelqu'un qui
aurait appelé à des sanctions ça peut
être utilisé contre le journal contre le
média pour dire qu' il y a eu un appel
est donc cette loi peut-être de toutes
façons de mise en place même contre le
média donc en fait il y à vraiment
aujourd'hui un sentiment qu'on ne peut
plus rien dire qu'on ne peut plus rien
publié c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que de
très nombreuses rédactions faire mouvoir
quitte aujourd'hui la russie on disait
que les sanctions économiques ne peuvent
pas avoir d'effet immédiat mais en fait
la chute du rouble à ce qu'elle peut
avoir des conséquences très rapide pour
les russes et est-ce que d'après vous
les sanctions qui ont été prises ça va
souder les russes derrière le chef le
président vladimir poutine au contraire
ça va accentuer la défiance envers le
pouvoir alors je pense que l'opinion ne
réagit pas directement
aux sanctions aux conséquences sociales
parce que il faut il faut dissocier deux
choses d'abord effectivement ces
sanctions sans précédent et cette chute
du rouble vertigineuse évidemment
qu'elle va avoir des conséquences pour
les russes on va recommencer à mettre de
l'argent liquide sous son matelas il va
y avoir une inflation une inflation
galopante la chute du pouvoir d'achat et
puis le retrait de toutes les
entreprises étrangères de russie
finalement c'est on a l'impression qu'on
retourne quelque part derrière le rideau
de fer et ce modèle de consommation qui
tournait à l'intérieur de la russie
qu'on va être coupée du monde je veux
dire il qui a se retire le système pay
pal se retire bon là on est en train de
se renfermer donc ça évidemment les
russes qui ont pris l'habitude depuis
trente ans de vivre dans une société
très occidentalisée finalement malgré le
régime mais si on ne se préoccupe pas de
la politique on est vraiment dans une
société de consommation sur le modèle
occidental donc ça évidemment les rues
selon le ressortir très fortement
maintenant est-ce que ça va et re est
mené à une érosion du soutien à vladimir
poutine au contraire au renforcement ce
sont des mécanismes très complexe il ya
là d'abord la propagande qui cette
propagande de guerre un très très dur
qui nourrit ce sentiment de frustration
et de ressentiment envers les
occidentaux parce qu'on dit qu on nous
attaque c'est à cause d'eux que cela
arrive et non pas à cause de vladimir
poutine donc on vit en russie dans un
système non seulement qui se renferme on
va être obligés d'adhérer un message sur
mon neveu si on ne peut pas partir par
exemple qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien on
doit trouver son compte là on se trouve
donc à défaut de pouvoir haïr son
dirigeant envahir l'occident qui selon
la propagande nous attaquent donc voyez
cette semaine un mécanisme très complexe
évidemment au fond le sentiment
d'adhésion envers bladimir poutine il
n'est plus là depuis longtemps il a eu
le coc vide la lutte désastreuse les
effets désastreux du coc vider la
gestion désastreuse de la russie du coc
vide il ya eu la réforme
constitutionnelle de vladimir poutine ça
fait un moment déjà que soit sa cote de
popularité est en train de ses rosés
mais on voit selon le reste le dernier
sondage de l'institut d'étude d'opinion
levada par exemple qu'aujourd'hui la 70%
des cotes de confiance sur fond de cette
opération contre l'ukraine donc on voit
que la propagande joue son rôle joue
sont en effet maintenant est ce que
réellement il ya un soutien ou bien et
c'est tout simplement la peur qui fait
répondre les gens c'est quand même
quelque chose qui va falloir réaliser
plus sur le long terme est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya des fissures qui peuvent
apparaître qu'ils apparaissent déjà dans
les secteurs militaires économiques
voire politiques alors
les fissures et bon les militaires on a
pu parler d'ailleurs avec quelques
militaires qui remontait déjà du front
dans un train de nuit vers moscou depuis
belgrade ils nous disent qu'ils ne
savaient absolument pas pourquoi ils
partaient en ukraine on leur a dit
jusqu'au bout qu'ils allaient effectuer
des manoeuvres et c'est donc est ce que
les soldats eux-mêmes après il se pose
pas de question les soldats russes ils
ce sont des soldats ils sont mobilisés
ils vont se battre et puis ils sont
aussi quelque part imprégné par cette
propagande qui dit aujourd'hui que les
hommes russes doivent rendre hommage à
leur grand père qui ont combattu les
nazis et qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
cette même lutte contre les nazis qui
ont pris le pouvoir en ukraine et c'est
donc bon il y a une certaine adhésion à
ce message maintenant la vraie question
c'est pas tant la fissure le système est
tellement verrouillé que les petits
maillons du système n'ont pas vraiment
droit droit de prise de parole ou de
rébellion et cetera parce qu'il ya une
répression très forte la vraie question
c'est de savoir est-ce que fissures il
ya au sommet de l'état parmi le premier
cercle de vladimir poutine parmi les on
sait enfin parmi les oligarques parmi
pas parmi les parmi les trucs les les
responsables des structures de sécurité
1 qui dirige le pays parce que ça c'est
très important c'est un pays vladimir
poutine et l'ancien chef du fsb l'ancien
agent du kgb et le pays aujourd'hui est
dirigée par ces structures totalement
pas paranoïaque 1 qui lui présente une
carte du monde qui n'est kiné qui n'est
pas la réalité de 2,2 ce qu'elle est en
voilà de ce qu'elle est réellement et
donc du coup la question c'est ça acs
qui lie à une fissure au sommet de
l'état est ce que est ce qu'il va y
avoir des mets des mécanismes dans ce
sens là on a absolument aucun ninsight
nature n'a aucune formation chine
informations pour les la non mais je
vais pas m'avancer mais ça ce serait
intéressant de suivre et de le savoir
est ce que vladimir poutine est tout
seul ou est ce que il y à une élite
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un gros sensuelle
et qu'il dise qu'il va qui pourrait lui
dire qu'il va trop loin et qu'il va trop
loin ou bien au contraire à ce qu'il ait
un consensus dans cette opération contre
l'ukraine et c'est cet impérialisme
aujourd'hui militaire ça ne sais pas
merci beaucoup et léna volochine pour
votre décryptage